TWO TOP TRANSGENDERED DOCTORS
ARE SOUNDING THE ALARM AND
PUTTING THE WELL BEING OF THE
CHILDREN AHEAD OF THE LEFT'S
AGENDA.
MEDICAL EXPERTS SAID WE HAVE
GONE TOO FAR WHEN IT COMES TO
THE USE OF PURSUANT BLOCKERS AND
GENDER IN YOUNG KIDS THE
ESTABLISHMENT AND THE MEDIA
WON'T LISTEN TO THEM.
WHY?
BECAUSE WHETHER OR NOT ANYONE
WHETHER A 9-YEAR-OLD ASSIGNMENT
SURGERY OR OBJECTS TO A
BIOLOGICAL MALE COMPETING IN
WOMEN'S SPORTS ENEMY OF PUBLIC
MOB.
NO ONE KNOWS BETTER THAN THESE
TWO DOCTORS.
FIGHTING BACK AGAINST THE UP BE
FAIR COMPETITION.
THEY JOIN ME WITH THEIR ATTORNEY
CHRISTIANA HOLCOMB.
THANKS FOR COME ON.
ALANNA, TELL ME A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT YOUR STORY AND EXPERIENCE
HAS BEEN.
>> UM, MY FRESHMAN YEAR OF HIGH
SCHOOL I COMPETED AGAINST TWO
BIOLOGICAL MALES AND IT WAS JUST
REALLY DEMORALIZING TO KNOW THAT
ALL OF MY HARD WORK AND ALL THE
OTHER FEMALE ATHLETES' HARD WORK
WASN'T PAYING OFF AND WE WERE
REALLY JUST RACING FOR SECOND
AND THIRD PLACE AND WE WEREN'T
GOING TO GET THE SPOTS THAT WE
REALLY TRULY DESERVED TO GET.
>> Ben: SALEENNA, TELL ME ABOUT
YOUR EXPERIENCE.
>> I WAS FORCED TO COMPETE ABOUT
BLIGE MALES AGAINST ALL FOUR
YEARS ON HIGH SCHOOL I LOST OUT
ON COUNTLESS OPPORTUNITIES
PRIMARILY THE NEW ENGLAND CHAMP
CHAMPIONSHIPS IF THEY WEREN'T
THERE I WOULD HAVE QUALIFIED.
I HAVE HAD WHO COMPETE AGAINST
THESE ATHLETES OVER A DOZEN
TIMES.
EVERY SINGLE TIME I LOST WITHOUT
FEEL.
FAIL.
>> Ben: CHRISTIANNA, IT SEEMS
LIKE ME THIS IS A SITUATION
WHERE YOU ARE FORCED TO GET
INVOLVED IN LITIGATION AND IN
FIGHTS BUT YOU NEVER REALLY WANT
TO AS A DISTRACTION DURING YOUR
HIGH SCHOOL YEARS AND THE LIKE.
WHAT ARE THE LEGAL ASPECTS OF
THESE FIGHTS AS YOU SEE THEM
PLAYING OUT ACROSS THE COUNTRY?
>> GIRLS LIE LIKE CELINA AND
ALANNA HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THEIR BROTHER
VSSMENTS YOU AND I BOTH KNOW
THIS ISSUE IS SO MUCH BIGGER
THAN JUST SPORTS.
RADICAL ACTIVISTS INCLUDING
THOSE IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, ARE THREATENING
THOSE WHO STAND UP FOR BASIC
FACTS ABOUT BIOLOGY AND THE FACT
THAT HUMANS ARE EITHER MALE OR
FEMALE AND, YOU KNOW, WE SEE
THIS IDEOLOGY PLAY OUT WITH REAL
HUMAN COSTS.
WOMEN ARE BEING FORCED AND
TRAPPED IN PRISON CELLS WITH
VIOLENT MALE CRIMINALS.
WE SEE PARENTS WHO ARE EITHER
PUSHED OUT OF THE CONVERSATION
ENTIRELY OR ARE INTIMIDATED INTO
PUTTING THEIR CHILDREN ON
HORMONES OR UNDERGOING LIFE
ALTERING SURGERIES.
EVEN WOMEN ARE BROADLY BEING
DEHUMANIZED BY BEING REFERRED TO
AS CHEST FEEDERS OR BIRTHING
PEOPLE.
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON.
THAT'S WHY DEFENDING FREEDOM AND
A BROAD COALITION ARE STANDING
UP FOR BASIC TRUTH AND BASIC
BIOLOGY AND TO PROTECT WOMEN AND
GIRLS LIKE CELINA AND ALANNA.
>> Ben: ALANNA, TELL ME A LITTLE
BIT AND I WILL ASK YOU AS WELL,
CELINA.
WHAT WAS THE REACTION AMONG YOUR
FRIENDS AND PARENTS, AMONG
PEOPLE YOU TALKED TO WHEN YOU
TRIED TO TALK TO THEM ABOUT THE
CHALLENGE OF GOING THROUGH WHAT
SEEMED TO BE SUCH AN UNFAIR
EXPERIENCE?
>> WELL, MY FRIENDS AND FAMILY
SUPPORTED WHAT I WAS COOKING AND
THEY THOUGHT IT WAS GREAT THAT I
WAS FIGHTING FOR WOMEN'S SPORTS
AND ENSURING THAT WE WEREN'T
BECOMING SIDELINED IN OUR OWN
SPORT.
THE ONLY BACKLASH I REALLY GOT
WAS ON SOCIAL MEDIA FROM PEOPLE
THAT I DIDN'T KNOW.
>> Ben: UM-HUH.
CELINA, WAS IT THE SAME
EXPERIENCE FOR YOU?
>> I HAD SAME EXPERIENCE AS
ALANNA, I HAVE GOTTEN NOTHING
BUT LOVE AND SUPPORT FROM MY
FAMILY.
MY PARENTS HAVE BEEN FIGHTING
THIS ALONGSIDE WITH ME AND I
ALSO HAVE ONLY REALLY GOTTEN
HATE FROM SOCIAL MEDIA BUT I
JUST FOCUS ON ALL THE LOVE AND
SUPPORT.
>> Ben: CELINENA, DO YOU FEEL
LIKE THIS IS ONE OF THOSE ISSUES
WHERE THE NATIONALIZED NATURE OF
SOCIAL MEDIA.
THE INTERNATIONALIZED NATURE OF
IT BASICALLY ALLOWS JUST ABOUT
ANYBODY IN THE WORLD TO TAKE POT
SHOTS AT YOU WHETHER THEY KNOW
YOU OR NOT, WHETHER THEY'RE
GOING TO YOUR SCHOOL OR PART OF
YOUR COMMUNITY OR NOT THAT
THAT'S REALLY WHAT KIND OF
DRIVES THIS DISCUSSION NOW AS
OPPOSED TO LETTING PLACES DECIDE
PARENTS AND STUDENTS DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES HOW THINGS LIKE THIS
OUGHT TO BE GOVERNED?
>> I THINK THAT SOCIAL MEDIA IS
A BIG FACTOR IN THIS BECAUSE
PEOPLE GET A BOOST OF CONFIDENCE
BY HIDING BEHIND A PHONE SCREEN.
BUT IT'S JUST REALLY UNFORTUNATE
SITUATION BECAUSE IT SHOULD BE
ACCEPTED THAT WOMEN'S SPORTS
NEED TO BE KEPT AS JUST WOMEN'S
SPORTS.
>> Ben: UM-HUH.
ALANNA, IN TERMS OF YOUR OWN
EXPERIENCE, THIS HAS TO BE
SOMETHING THAT IS DISCOURAGING,
BUT HAVE YOU TAKEN SOME SILVER
LINING OUT OF THE FACT THAT YOU
HAVE GOTTEN THAT LEVEL OF
SUPPORT THAT YOU MENTIONED FROM
YOUR FRIENDS AND FAMILY?
>> YEAH.
IT MAKES ME FEEL REALLY PROUD
THAT MY STORY HAS MADE IT SO FAR
AND THAT HOPEFULLY IT WILL HELP
MORE FEMALE ATHLETES TO STAND UP
SO CHANGE CAN BE MADE QUICKER
AND SO THAT WOMEN'S SPORTS CAN
STAY WOMEN'S SPORTS AND WE CAN
CONTINUE TO COMPETE ON A LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD.
>> Ben: YOU NOPE, IT REALLY
SEEMS TO ME THAT THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT INVADES OUR
COMMUNITIES AND CREATES SUCH A
HARD QUESTIONS FOR PARENTS AND
FOR COMMUNITIES TO FACE IN WAYS
THAT ARE REALLY UNFAIR TO ALL OF
THE GIRLS WHO ARE INVOLVED.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU BOTH FOR
BEING BRAVE ENOUGH TO STAND UP
AND TO PUSH BACK AGAINST WHAT IS
AN AGENDA THAT OBVIOUSLY HAS
ENORMOUS BACKINGS FROM VERY
POWERFUL PEOPLE BUT REALLY
DOESN'T REPRESENT WHAT THE
COMMUNITIES OR PARENTS OR EVEN
THE FEMALE STUDENTS INVOLVED
REALLY WANT FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING ME
TONIGHT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Ben: DON'T GO ANYWHERE.
ABBY HORNACEK IS HERE AND S